[Music]
hello okay
thanks for the thanks for having me and
thanks for staying to the very end I
know it's been a long long couple of
talks so I'll keep this sort of no
technical should be light on technical
side maybe slightly heavy on other
topics we'll see how it goes so I'm a
data scientist I did a data science team
trained first QA we do software testing
as a service but today the talk will be
about something totally different
as I deal with sort of AI and machine
learning at work I have started to think
are there some ethical implications to
the things that we do and if you have
been to any conferences like PI data or
Europe pythons last year I've been to a
few of those and I thought it was really
cool there were lots of new
visualization techniques and bit of deep
learning and machine learning in general
and it was cool but you know the the
topic of ethics was not touched on as
much this year this really changed if
you've been to you know you've seen at
this conference and also many others
this year people are really starting to
think about this and try to figure out
what are the real world implications of
of the things we do as a data scientist
so I think that's that's really good
people are thinking about it there's
lots of things that we do actually do
have real important impact on the world
and just as a note as a bonus there is a
couple of references to British pop
culture and if you get something shout
before we dive in I just want to credit
a few people that have been talking
about things connected to this generally
first of all you probably all know
Katherine she's a badass
she gave a really good keynote about
interpretable models and she touched on
you know it's it's a topical very well
connected to ethics but there are also
other people so for examples then to
fact see
she describes herself as a techno
sociologist she has a background in
technology now she's doing research in
sociology and she talks about the things
that I will talk about today but also
more generally about how technology
impacts the world about how protesting
changed with Twitter and Facebook and so
on and finally Cathy O'Neil wrote this
sort of Bible of of this topic the
weapons of mass destruction if what I'm
what I'm telling you today
sounds interesting definitely going with
this book it's very scary but I think a
very important read so I will basically
rehash lots of things that they have
said before much better so if you're
interested please go and look them up
does anyone know what this is so this is
deep thought it's the computer that was
built in Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy and it was built by super
intelligent multi dimensional beings to
give the answer to life universe and
everything so you know the super
dimensional super intelligent hyper
dimensional beings basically got fed up
with existential angst and they wanted
the answer so they decided to build a
super powerful computer and when they
did and they went to it and say hey
please give us the answer to life in
averse and everything at which point the
computer said okay I need seven million
years to do the computation but you know
what's a bit of waiting in exchange for
such an important thing so they did they
waited seven million years they came
back at which point deep thought said
that the answer is 42 but it doesn't
know what the question is so you know
why am I telling you this it's sort of a
silly science fiction story but I think
one of the reasons why Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy is such a funny book
and is because it has some very pointed
criticisms at how our society works and
how people tend to think and this is
kind of illustrated in this example
first of all if your question is rubbish
you will not get a useful answer and
that's probably obvious to everyone of
you but it's not always obvious as you
work and there will be an example later
on but second of all why did
super-intelligent hyper tournament
dimensional beings decide to build a
supercomputer to answer this question
why didn't they for example decide to
create a well-funded philosophy
department and sort this out maybe it
would take less than seven million years
and maybe there would get an answer that
you can actually use and I think one of
the reasons they decided to build the
computer is because we tend to think
that computers are objective right they
are governed by ones and zeroes and
logic gates and transistors and
algorithms and they have no morals so
they cannot be biased and they're always
fair and they always true now if you've
been to sort of this conference at least
you already know that this is not
necessarily the case and so you know
there might be computers are not always
right but maybe when they are wrong they
are wrong in obvious ways like when CNN
misclassifies a catch as a penguin it's
really obvious to us you know there's a
mistake it's kind of harmless it's a bit
absurd we might have a chuckle so it's
no big deal
but there are also cases where you can't
actually tell whether computers are
wrong or not whether the answer is a
giving you are correct and also the the
kind of mistakes that algorithms tend to
make are usually very different than
mistakes that humans tend to make and we
also come back to that okay so first of
all is there anyone here that thinks
that that's two things that computers
cannot be biased awesome okay part of my
work is already done so I will tell you
a little story you might have seen this
already does anyone know where this
comes from okay I'll go over it quickly
because there's lots of sources
explaining its bus there was an article
written and ProPublica last year and
2016 and it was describing the case of
these two people among other cases so
the person on the left her name is
Britta and a guy on the right his name
is Vernon they have both been convicted
of a crime in Florida and Florida is
sort of a very specific place in the
u.s. in terms of it
the criminal system but it illustrates
the point point very well so Britta was
she was I think 18 or 19 she was working
somewhere and she saw a kid's bike lying
on the side of the road she picked it up
she started sucking on it and then threw
it away started running away but her
like the mother of the kids that I
belonged to saw her called the police
and she was arrested the bike was worth
around $80 I think very non was arrested
for shoplifting something of similar
value so they were both arrested and
they were you know put through the
criminal system and one of the quicks in
Florida is that there is the system
called compass that scores the
recidivism risk so everyone who is
arrested for some kind of crime gets put
through a system and if the score is
high that means that the system thinks
that this person is more likely to
reoffend if it's low it's less at least
less likely to reoffend and this is
still you know given to the judge and
the judge makes the decision so it's not
that the algorithm is sort of the
ultimate judge but it's still taken into
account in this case Trisha was given
high risk of recidivism Brennan was
given low risk so that was 2014 by the
time the article was written in 2016 we
already knew that the algorithm got it
wrong so after two years Trisha did not
reoffend and friend that he was trying
to do I think still something much more
expensive from some warehousing who was
arrested again so you know maybe it's
not a big deal like if we put aside the
whole issue of letting algorithms decide
anything of importance about humans
which might be questionable as well but
let's accept that for now you know
algorithms make mistakes we accept it
they're not perfect there is some kind
of level of accuracy they just have to
be good enough the problem is that they
might actually be biased in a specific
way and you can probably see where this
is going so ProPublica the investigative
journalists found that the algorithms
actually racially biased so while it's
miss pacifies white people and black
people at small as the same rates it
makes different mistakes so it's when
it's misclassifies a black person it
tends to assign them higher risk and mr.
misclassifying a white person tends to
assign them lower risk
and so after this product article was
published there has been some rebuttals
and sort of very in-depth analysis it's
very again scary but kind of fun topic
to explore and read about but just
really scare example of how you can take
something like predictive policing that
seems objective and I'm sure no one
designing the system actually tried to
make it racist it's just the way it
worked out another thing that I probably
don't have to explain so it's been
mentioned at least twice even earlier
today I was talking about word vectors
and how they can be bias this anyone
think or is does anyone agree it does
anyone disagree that what word vectors
can be biased okay so we all know they
can be but I think it still there's an
important point here that bears
repeating the paper that discovered this
also proposed ways of dealing with this
so you can basically if you have this
high dimensional space of word vectors
you can affect you can pre-process the
training data to effectively sort of
squish and stretch the hyper space in
different ways to make sure that the
words that you think should be fused
together are close together and ones
that shouldn't be are not but the
critical point here is that this is not
automatic we need our human judgment to
make this decision some relationships
like you know king and queen we want to
preserve that
but relationship that that was given in
the paper like computer programmer and
house maker that's something we don't
want to preserve but it's still in the
data so there's we have to sort of get
rid of our illusion of okay we're just
objective we're looking at the data
because the data is biased our world is
not fair
so if you are saying you know if you try
to give away this responsibility you're
actually reinforcing biases biases that
exist so if you want to be fair you have
to do something about it
on a slightly lighter note I'm sure
everyone knows who this is so you know
you might you might say okay sure I've
got a dataset
there are a bunch of things in there
that I do not want to discriminate on
like race or gender or you know whatever
you can think of whatever is appropriate
for the application so let's just get
rid of those characteristics I'll just
drop these columns and my whatever
algorithm I use model I train will not
use them well it's not so easy you know
you can for example if you drop the
column containing people's gender your
argument might still end what the gender
is implicitly by its own name or
interests or you know many other
characteristics so it's actually quite
difficult to make sure that your model
doesn't focus on things that you don't
want it to focus on and this is
important for a bunch of reasons first
of all you might think that doing some
of this taking decisions based on some
of these is just an ethical in many
places there are actual legal
requirements so in the u.s. there is
this concept of disparate impact and
there's an actual formula that you can
apply a tree the algorithm is a black
box and basically see what goes in and
what comes out and if someone is able to
prove that your argument is biased in in
a specific way according to this formula
you can be sued so it's really important
even as even if you didn't care about
ethics to think about this and another
example that's it comes from a talk from
zhenya bliss already mentioned she was
at some point to the conference for a
from HR for HR professionals and it was
fairly recently so you know ai ai is all
the hype and if you've ever done any
hiring you know that sifting through
hundreds of CVS is a huge pain neck so
people are really excited about
automatically matching CVS to job to
open positions and discarding deposits
are and not suitable so let's keep that
on the side for now there were two
papers fairly recently one based on data
from Twitter one based on data from
Instagram that were able to predict when
people will get depressed based on your
social media posts these algorithms were
sorry were able to detect signs of
depression
before it was diagnosed
now imagine that this algorithm for
doing job matching uses data from your
company right you have a bunch of people
already hired some of them are high
performers some of them I not and you
train an auger and try to figure out
okay I want more people like that and
less people less fewer people like that
and even without you knowing for example
the algorithm might have access to
social media the algorithm might learn
that's all right this person you know
got depressed three months into the job
and they performed terribly and might
discriminate against them without you
even knowing this and that's the scary
part and it's obviously very ethically
questionable and also illegal to do
something like that but if you just
train algorithm and give a data it might
do it anyway without you know it so
that's something that's very important
to keep in mind and the other thing that
I already kind of mentioned is
unintuitive errors and has just the idea
that the errors that computers make are
very different to our human errors so
just here at nips is the first time they
are organizing a adversarial learning
competition so the aim is to create
let's say you know we have a model like
an image and model classifying images
into classes and the aim is to create an
image that looks totally fine to human
and gets consistently misclassified by
ogron's so you can add specific noise
patterns in different ways to make that
make sure that the cat is always
classified as a penguin for example and
the competition is you know on one hand
people will try to fool the models on
the other hand people will try to create
models that are robust to do this kind
of thing but the thing is that we as a
society have been developing for quite
quite a long time trying to learn how to
deal with our own their own human biases
like if you think about how the justice
system tends to work and many other
examples they are kind of built around
making sure that you know human biases
are somehow balanced the same metals
don't necessarily work for machines
because they tend to make very different
mistakes I promise to come back to
stupid questions anyone knows this
screenshot multiplied some so stupid
questions that was
knights of the round table were had to
cross the bridge and the question turned
out to be what's your name and what's
your favorite color
but this is a paper that has also been
making rounds a while ago just keep in
mind that this paper was put on archives
but it was not actually peer-reviewed so
you know it's a terrible paper but at
least it wasn't be reviewed and accepted
but basically what they try to do here
is - they try to classify people as
criminals and non-criminals based on
single facial photograph and the row on
the top shows criminals and their own
the bottom shows no criminals so what
did this algorithm learn you know that
people who don't smile are criminals or
people in white colors are definitely
not criminals we know that's not true
right so it's just important to and you
know they just I think they just used
Alex NAT sort of put it through your net
and intent something and it was heavily
criticized so you know our community at
least is at least somewhat resistant to
to things like that but it's very
important to keep in mind not to ask
silly questions and this is much more
recent from September it was written by
yelling Wang and macaque Hinske and as
everyone does anyone know Makoku
schinsky
okay so that's just an aside but it's
also very interesting how coach in ski
is a researcher also one kind of
intersection between psychology and
computer science and a bunch of years
ago he came up with the method to
classify people into to predict people's
like Big Five personality traits so
there's like agreeable conscientiousness
and so on based on Facebook Likes and
that caused Facebook to sort of
immediately shut off people's access to
this data and so on but the scary thing
was that a few years later this exact
research was apparently used by
Cambridge analytical which is a company
that sort of lobbying and researching
company and apparently they have used
similar techniques to influence people
during brexit referendum and
presidential election in the US last
year so that just shows you how scary
these things can be and how much impact
they can have
and again there are articles about the
detailing I encourage you to tweet about
so this was much more recent paper by
and hakushin's kids well and in here
they also divided people into two
categories
can you guess what these two categories
are okay let me rephrase it they
categorize both men and women into two
different categories these categories
are heterosexual and homosexual this
paper was peer-reviewed and will
actually appear in a psychological
journal at some point I'm not sure when
it was still heavily criticized it
definitely has problems and so let's
just talk about a few of them I'm not
here to sort of pick on this paper I
think it's a very interesting case to
think about first of all is it ethical
to even publish something like this
regardless of whether it's right or
wrong
on one hand to sort of giving a tool out
to people you might say a weapon not a
tool and it's very easy to imagine how
something like this can be weaponized to
actually hurt people so you know it's
very morally questionable whether it's
the right thing to do on the other hand
I haven't told you anything about how
this is actually done but most of you
can probably imagine and you can get
this data yourself and you can actually
build something like this fairly easily
so the tools are already there so
probably there are already people trying
to do this and releasing this paper am I
just fired up the debate about this and
maybe actually make people conscious of
the problem so maybe it's a good thing
to do it's hard to say
they're also some sort of flaws in the
paper they they try to make sure that
they don't take into account things like
you know the angle at which you take
your selfie and the environment you're
in and the grooming style of your face
and so on but it's I think it's very
difficult to actually do so it's hard to
say whether the model is picking up on
actual facial features like width of
your nose or whatever or you know
something that doesn't actually tell you
anything about the human but about the
human you know how their face looks like
but like how they live
okay last thing I want to mention is the
power of the machine so that might be
fairly obscure here this is from a show
called Little Britain and this is Carol
and Carol is a receptionist and she sort
of helps people and like banks and
hospitals and whenever someone comes
over to get help to you know sort
something out she does a bit of that and
that says computer says no and it just I
mean it's really silly but it just
illustrates that this these things that
we have built that were meant to make
our life easier and make us faster and
more efficient and happier are sometimes
just brought looks and what we try to do
and if the computer says no you know you
can't argue with it you can't convince
it to say something else and you know
Carol might not have the power to
actually help you and this applies
everywhere so in Katherine has a really
interesting talk to a Python this year
also a keynote where she mentioned the
automatic check writing system so at
some point in some bank can't remember
where it was they developed a method to
write checks automatically and suddenly
that was amazing because they could and
also was just the time when they wanted
to expand and that allowed them to
actually expand and be much more
efficient and so on and that's great but
maybe if they didn't have this option if
they didn't have computers maybe they
also have to innovate in a different way
maybe they would have to change the
organizational structure and maybe have
to decentralize maybe hire more people
you know there are different
opportunities and even though a
technical solution might be great I
think we should think about other ones
as well just to make sure we're not
taking the easiest way out that it's not
necessarily optimal so what I would like
you to do as you're building machine
learning models first of all read up on
this topic there are lots of references
that how I try to put a link to
afterwards and read about it start
thinking about it whenever you're
building a machine learning model
consider the impact it might have on the
world whether it's actually doing what
you think it's doing
and you know maybe join Amitabh specific
to this maybe join a political party if
you care about it the message is that we
are not we are not objective in our work
and what we do has real implications on
the world so computers can be [ __ ]
because we make them so please don't
thank you thank you so much Fred talk I
think it was very inspirational
especially 242 yeah and in fact during
the tutorials I had a short discussion
over the image recognition and we
discuss briefly the problem like the
idea to find sexuality of the person and
based on the face right but I didn't
know it it already done so all right
so--okay you have questions to our
speaker yeah
okay yeah you know this paper about okay
blog post the TV train work to work by
default is racist sexist etc so for
example if you have nations and say all
like good versus bad and you get well
some more origination says good right
and other as bad for example and they
say but for me I was curious is how to
create a human baseline because they
could because well it may happen that
machines are like say East intersection
aspects the questions is if it's an
improvement or own performance so I
guess juries also are heavy biased in
the US and is it question does it
amplify it or reduce it or is the same
sure it's a great question i I don't
think there is a right answer it really
depends on the data you use and the
application use it for like if you want
to just explore biases that we have like
pre-trained war Tuvok is awesome because
it shows you exactly that so it's the
right tool for the job
but you know for other cases it might
not be so and I'm not I'm not trying to
say that you shouldn't use algorithms
you're right that in some cases even
algorithms you know they might not be
perfect they might still be biased in
some way but if they're better than
humans maybe that's good but what I am
trying to sort of fight is the
perception of algorithms are objective
and have no morals they do have embedded
morals in them so it's just important to
consider that and try to contract it
okay question
cd1 very silly when it comes to like
criminals is there something like
presentation so you have some dreamed
criminal and greed dreamed innocent
person when a machine tries to well
abstract face so I mean I suspect
probably and it's kind of funny when you
read this paper about detecting sexual
orientation and it's sort of the first
thing they do in the interaction is
saying you know fees
was it frenetic sore physiognomy is you
know this thing is terrible and it's the
can't remember the name is this area
that was really popular sort of
pseudo-scientific as we now know that
was real popular in 18th century where
people were trying to predict oh yeah
this is a criminal because you know his
nose is wide or whatever it turned out
that it's all sort of you know racism
and and other biases hidden behind
pseudoscience so this is the first thing
they claimed in the paper because they
don't want to do that and but at the
same time there are things that might
actually link character to faces for
example I mean I'm just basically
rehashing what they said people who are
attractive are you know tend to be
perceived differently by other people so
the experiences with people are
different so they that might develop the
character just because of how they look
like so there might be at least this
link between face and character and
there might be many others it doesn't
mean that you know it's not as trivial
as like big forehead or small forehead
but there might be some links so to link
back to what you said maybe in different
countries because of cultural
differences these relationships are
slightly different and they might
manifest themselves in different ways
some of them might affect how people
actually look like but it would be a
really interesting research to do like
create an eigen face of a criminal in
per country I'm not aware of that but I
guess it's an opportunity okay so thank
you okay any more comments or questions
first thing actually I had a comment
about the the criminal face I think I
read an article where they took like a
whole bunch of pictures of criminals and
then just like set them one on another
and took like this sort of okay I don't
know what to call like a mix and it
actually turns out to be kind of like an
average good-looking person because just
sort of everything sort of kind of evens
out and then you end up with somebody
that's just sort of oh it's just the
person but actually my question is more
towards when where do we stop like
eliminating features and keeping it like
having the algorithm actually work right
and keeping it ethical let's say okay so
we get rid of gender we get rid of race
so then maybe the algorithm makes the
decision on age well then that's ageism
then so we get rid of age so I don't
know we look at how people are dressed
and we see that people who wear jeans
cause you know create more crime than
people who wear slacks so do we get rid
of that I mean you know where's the line
and I mean if everything is evenly
distributed then we can't really make a
classifier anyways so how do we deal
with with this ethics and you know a
good classifier sure I mean that's
that's definitely an open question and I
think it was one of the points that
Katherine was trying to make the keynote
yesterday that's there are so many open
problems here that you know the it's
ripe for the field is ripe for picking
and like but there are some suggestions
like this this idea of disparate impact
is one that's that sometimes applicable
so you have to but again it's not it's
not automatic you have to apply your
human judgments and you say okay these
are the values I believe in I want my
algorithm to do this and I'm going to
check it against that there's no way to
say you know just make it unbiased or
check if like you have to know what
you're looking for but the disparate
impact thing basically treats things as
black boxes and if you you know you can
sort of vary the inputs try to preserve
for example race or gender
depends on what your classic flying and
see what comes out like if everything
let's say every sample that's that has a
specific gender is misclassified in the
specific way you know you have a problem
so the best answer I have is just think
of how it could break how it could be
biased and try to find it I'm sure there
are many other things we could be doing
but we need people to actually find
those ok any more questions I think that
we can try to make this topic a little
bit more longer like making a blogger
presentation during our meetup Michael
the next one or think about it and we
can do this caching afterwards that
might be a good like a ending
presentation but then a discussion
afterwards so if you wanna if you have
an idea how to for example contribute to
this you can like joint one or something
like that all the ideas open so thank
you so much thank you
[Applause]
you